coming up next
[Music]
I like this one um salmon and asparagus
that's a favorite mine she's good as a
guy is that a is that a do you think
that's a red flag
I know you're gonna miss me let me take
a look at the
hello we doing a deep in introspect
foreign
[Music]
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Red Pill Bachelor
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and subscribe
to the channel today we have a special
guest on the red pill Bachelor mediocre
tutorials and reviews 600
000 Instagram followers and really just
an OG in the manosphere space welcome to
the show thank you thank you thank you
for having me I'm super excited I don't
know what you guys got in store for me
but let's get active so tell me what
challenges have you found looking for
love what challenges have I not found
Pearl these modern women today all right
listen at the end of the day it's
difficult out here in these streets you
know what I mean for them to recognize
me for who I am and be a marriageable
material okay it's tough I just run into
so much delusion and unrealistic
expectation understand is I'm just
looking for the right one at the end of
it and what qualities are you hoping
fine today
oh the typical that I would say that
most men are looking for I'm an easy guy
to please all right give me that
feminine beautiful intelligent
inspirational and talented that's the
one that a lot of people don't think
about talented she's a high achiever
High achieving women you got that for me
you know we put together some of the
best women that I've met on the show
some quality
beautiful women that we're gonna bring
for you today boom and what are you
looking for
I'm looking for
you know dope a dope young lady I mean
that's really it at the end of it is you
know I've been single for a long time a
lot of people don't know this is that
I've been single since College wow yeah
so it's been a while 37 years right now
I've been single since then so it's
about time it's about time you settle
down do you think you can make the
distance work with with the London gals
out here uh Pearl I I don't know they
gonna have to relocate probably I don't
think I don't think that the long
distance thing makes a lot of sense at
all but they can come to you right they
can absolutely come to me and what do
you bring to the table for these women
uh you know what a man I mean at the end
of the day
it's okay I'm joking yeah so you know um
what's it what would it be like dating
you what do they get well I think that a
intelligent mature Lee thinking young
woman should be looking for a guy that
is a leader and I pride myself off of my
leadership capabilities I'm financially
stable I'm doing decently for myself
and I can bring you to the promised land
and back at the end of the day so
good well
let's get the day
the dime let's find MTR love hey
there you go
you got this I
was born
you've got this don't worry
the name of the show space bar hit the
space bar
are you going to do the Spaceball space
bar oh yeah that's perfect
hey hey what's up I'm good how are you
Lauren Lauren it's a pleasure to meet
you nice to meet you I'm MTR nice to
meet you it's a pleasure to meet you
awesome awesome so tell me a little bit
about yourself
well as you can hear from my accent I am
not from London so start there I'm an
American Girl originally from Chicago
um I'm 33.
no kids never married and I am currently
residing in Arizona what brings you out
to London Town
so I
I go around to different
a lot as I'm single no kids I feel like
this is time to explore the world
got it okay awesome awesome are you
enjoying your time here I'm loving it
it's such a great City it doesn't
compare to Chicago though but it's a
good City it does it yeah so digital
nomad
lawyer 33 years old where do you see
yourself in the next like two to three
years like where do you you know not in
London somewhere else definitely
two to three years
um getting out of my system now I
definitely want to travel with my future
husband and kids but I do want to be
settled I want to move to the city that
my spouse is in settle down with them
and have a baby having a baby you ready
it's about it's about time well I do
want us to like enjoy each other for at
least a year or so beforehand
um you know kids come and the scene
change a little bit but
um yeah I'm ready I'm ready gotcha okay
so I guess you were deep into your
career throughout your 20s are you just
now deciding on the baby thing now or is
it something that you wanted to do
earlier but your career was in front of
that Pursuit that's a really questions
I've always
wanted them I think it's a matter for me
I do want to be prior to having kids so
that's important as well I think I need
it personally to go through some growth
and some changes right so
um schooling all of that finished
mid-20s and getting settled into the
career but to be honest I love what I do
I love my career I want to hold on to it
in some capacity but when it's time to
shift into the life mode into dating
things like that my priority is my
family right so I feel like I am
accomplished enough I love what I do but
I could put it on the back burner to
show up the way I need to show up to be
a wife to be a mother in this season so
I think I'm ready to accept all of that
how are the questions how's she
answering from from a guy's point of
view
uh married before they had a kid or what
what if y'all had a kid y'all decide
this ain't what I want to do no more
that's the whole point well that's the
point like a kid is a lifetime
commitment where like like people will
lock in and I will commit an entire life
to be related to you and raise a child
raise my DNA with you but a marriage
which you know can dissolve I don't know
it's just like weird to like it seems
backwards isn't it backwards I wish I
got a baby already locked in here no I'm
saying why have the baby first people
will commit to having a lifetime
commitment of a child together but not
marriage I wish I was married before it
was weird my children 100 in hindsight
obviously hindsight's a hell of a yeah
hell of a thing but in hindsight because
you have that also you have that
commitment of each other and you're so
solid together before to get married is
a bigger commitment isn't it no it's not
I don't mean than having children
children children is the biggest
obviously if he's committed to you it's
the woman's Choice whether she has a
child it's not the man's choice in once
she's pregnant so if he's committed to
her to the point of I want to marry you
at least you know he's not going to go
off he's not going anywhere he's there
with you and that child forever
once but once we had a baby we together
forever in a week wow I mean
even when they're winning like boyfriend
and girlfriend we tired yeah it's high
together but it doesn't mean that that
child's gonna have two parent household
and that is the best possible outcome
for a child and so it gives the woman
the security as well and the child and
the man you know that that man is fully
100 I think it's just like whether or
not you believe in marriage or not like
some people just don't believe in
marriage so there's no point in getting
married before they have a kid because
they don't believe in marriage but it's
like do you believe in marriage do you
want to do it with the state or do you
want to do a private ceremony but if you
do believe in marriage like I just don't
like it would make more sense to do that
before you have a kid because that's a
bigger commitment like America you can
get married to someone and divorce them
in a year and you can never see them
again but if you have a kid
you're with them for life so why
wouldn't you do the marriage first so
you say so you say go ahead and get
married first they had a baby yeah if
you believe in marriage if you don't
believe in marriage then
it's not really an option it's not ours
if you don't believe in marriage then
yeah
[Music]
you're gonna have paperwork if you have
a child though because your child
support's coming so like you're putting
yourself under you're putting you you
can have a choice to have certain
paperwork have it planned out Preen up
all that or just don't or don't do a
state or don't do a state one I I think
a lot of people aren't believing in the
State marriage license anymore like
Pearl was saying but at least a a
commitment but like if we're having a
baby together like you you get you you
can you can't you can't you catching
some paperwork don't play
well I think we should I think we're
gonna end it doesn't
a man of my mindset here's a couple of
things that I think through is that oh
what was that you ready
I better lay it all on you girl anyway
uh there's a couple of things that I
that I think through is is that um so
there's a concept that I often talk
about on my channel called conditional
femininity which is you know you come
off as an extremely feminine young woman
but I do understand that to be a lawyer
you know you got to be within your
masculine and as well do you think that
being feminine is a component of you or
is it a after thought after you know
what who you actually are yeah yeah I
think that's a real question
um and I will say I'm hardwired to be
that way I think all females are right
it's innate to us to be feminine and
things like that
um are there times of course where I
have to be more Stern more strict
masculine energy in my job absolutely
um and I think can that sometimes just
root being honest realistic can that
interfere or come at home
sometimes just being honest sometimes
you got to remember to take the head off
before you get to the door however with
that being said I'm also fully aware and
I would give the open door to my spouse
counterpart partner being able to tell
me hey you know you I know you had a
rough day at all but you home now like I
got you we good and in that moment you
can rest in that you can know all right
this is my man I could chill I can turn
it off sometimes I might need a reminder
but I think the femininity lays in being
able to rest in that into being able to
say you know right you're right this is
this is my safe place let me let me
settle here after having kids do you
want to work or do you want to be to
stay at home
while the kids are young
what would you prefer what would I
prefer I would prefer to work that's it
guy is that a is that a do you think
that's a red flag answer if you'd prefer
to work then be with your kids for guys
so see that that's all I was she just
said see but it's like you don't really
you don't really want your overlay to
work like you like if all things was in
the perfect world you would rather Java
put up and be where she ain't got to do
nothing but if she wanna do something
like you can't just
have her locked up in the crib like
because then when you come home she's
gonna be bossing your ass around
I think I think as a as a mother once
you have kids you've got to
sacrifice that part of your life
um it depends what your job is if you've
got like a job where you can stay at
home still and you know just do things
when they're asleep or napping and
that's fine but if you're if you're
using your time to work instead of the
you know devoting your time to your
children and raising them with like your
values and your you know way of thinking
and your life lessons then it's kind of
um
it doesn't really work and I mean you
can kind of tell from people who haven't
had their parents have haven't had their
mother around as much I think also when
you give birth you automatically change
like hormonally yeah that baby changes
something can you where you just don't
want to leave I've seen loads of friends
who have gone back to work and they just
Pine for being at home with their child
so I think she may change when after
she's
than hormones have hijacked your brain
and made you want to stay with this
little yeah and that's looking at you it
really depends on your
Sports into your setup like
do you is your mommy in your life you
got a grandparent in your life who can
take that load off of you got sisters do
you got close friends who you don't
trust with them kids so you can take a
second and go do this then well I'm just
got that then you're gonna have to be
there with them babies oh I'm just
thinking like because that's like 40
hours a week if you're working or 30 you
know I would think anyways so it's is
that at that point like aren't the
parents kind of raising your kid then
not you it's basically somebody else
raising your child that's why I was just
wondering from like a guy's point of
view and I know you said no but I wonder
if some guys like it is a red flag
because they would rather have someone
home with the kids because they're
choosing but I don't I don't raise my
all right my mama got them a superstar
while I was a baby so my grandparents
was Raising me but it ain't like I still
ain't learning from my mama you know
what I'm saying so it's all about your
support system like me if you guys know
support system do that then you're gonna
have to sit down with the kids I think
for the man isn't it now that he's
chosen her to raise his children not her
parents so if it's then like oh well
um I I like your parents but I didn't
choose to have a child with your parents
and so unless they've got pretty similar
values at him and her parents and the
child's gonna be raised differently
I don't know my my viewpoint is I think
this is very modern concept that just
the woman takes care of the child like
in in all of history there was a village
there was the generations of of each
other because one person is not enough I
think to give everything to a child
there's wisdom there's advice there's
there's different components so I think
today we're forced into this situation
where you know you work or you buy
yourself raising the child but that's
not ideal and again we live in the real
world so everyone doesn't have certain
situations but I I have seen I know in
my life and different people like I mean
I have a family over 100 people you know
all in the same area and I trust all of
them that you know they can go over the
cousin's house cousins go over here and
the aunts and the uncles and so
everyone's involved and cares and so I
think if you have that it is a a
privilege to do it but another thing
with working 40 hours a week you don't
factor into commute time getting ready
for work if you have projects or
deadlines you have to work on at night
um you know then you have to cook dinner
clean the house like there is a lot so
then what time do you really have for
the child other than like an hour or two
before you have to put them down for bed
every day from daycare
um and again it's not judging people's
situation you got to do what you have to
do but I think if you could stay at home
with the child until they go to school
then that would be important but then if
you stare step babies like you have one
every year and a half or two years
you're going to be out of the workforce
so this is a layered layer thing but I
think most men of means don't need their
woman to work I think the average man
today
can't support a household on one income
you know what's interesting Melanie I
just um I'm gonna do an episode of wife
school on this but I
there's a woman in Florida she raises 10
kids on ten thousand dollars a year
isn't that crazy wow ten thousand and
then what she and what she said and I'm
not gonna say this is like life
experience because it's not me but she
was saying that a lot of people just
don't want to go in lifestyle to spend
down in lifestyle to spend time with her
kids and the way she breaks it down is
she's saying like what do you need in a
year food clothing and shelter and she's
like a few of those three things like
there's a lot of like you can hand down
clothes for the kids you can make food
like she's like a garden food from
scratch and it's just I'm not saying
like everyone should do that but I think
there's a lot more leeway in that than a
lot of like modern women want to do yeah
I I I agree as you never know if you're
living like that I think so I I
homeschooled my two daughters the
difference I would read it two and three
I was away a lot because I was in the
military my daughter so my mum
predominantly looked after my daughter
and my daughter's attachment style my
son's attachment style because I'm so
present with my son a completely
different attachment styles are
important when the parent is not around
because if you guys don't know about
that I joined the military I joined the
military so when they when you grow up
into an adult and how you are in your
relationships whether you're anxious
whether you're avoidant if you've got
really secure attachment style when you
get into relationships it's usually a
healthy relationship a lot of anxious
people my daughter's extremely anxious
because from the age of one I was in the
military for six years so her first
memory well her first attachment thing
was me just leaving leaving her at my
mum's house for 14 weeks to do basic
training and then she came back and I
remember crying because she looked at me
like who are you yeah attachment I mean
that gets into layers I've actually
studied it and and gone deep into it but
attachment styles are the everyone has
an attachment style but it is the number
one thing that determines the outcome of
your relationship and your status a lot
of people have not gone into it
um but it's even if you have you know
insecurities three insecure attachment
Styles and there's only one secure one
the majority of people in the world have
an insecure attachment style that's
baked in before the age of seven but the
good news is no matter what it is it can
be changed
um and actually changed very quickly
just by learning you know different
things but that's not this
okay
okay that's not the norm it's not it
doesn't seem to be the norm no it seems
as though see what it is is that I think
um there's a thought of of uh wanting to
continue to work but I think a lot of
women today at the point that they have
kids if they really had the option like
it's one thing to say that now but when
you actually have it and then those
maternal instincts those hormones that
are now flooded throughout your body
kick in
many women want to actually you know be
at home with the kid if I have to be
honest I've never had that instinct my
instinct has always wanted to be able to
be able to balance it all right and
if needed I would but my preference what
I want to do is to be able to work
because I think that
um it's important to have that balance
right I want to make sure my kids have a
good education they have a great
influence and things like that but I
also want kids who can go out and
explore who can have opportunities to
travel and I think with a working mother
there's a different exposure to the
world than a mom that's staying at home
so and I understand that that's your
preference but what if I wanted you to
stay at home I would stay at home the
sacrifice that's my preference is but if
my husband wanted me to sacrifice that's
the role as a wife right like there's
compromise there's sacrifice me
personally right but your husband leaves
my husband's gonna leave and I always
people have asked me this for years like
oh you're this attorney blah blah blah
and I'm like I want to be married I want
to have kids I know that I will give it
up in a heartbeat to be with myself in a
heartbeat especially dating these these
days this is my failure so if I found
the one and that was the only thing
keeping us from that it's a
non-negotiable like all right I'll stay
at home I'll be here do you watch
YouTube
not like that what what what content do
you consume what like type of TV media
um honestly it would not a lot because I
think it's all filtered I think they
it's all an agenda right
um so on business I watch a lot of
business stuff because that's like my
field my Lane's so on YouTube I watch a
lot of iron gold and a lot of social
proofing a lot of
um what's the other guys um
I can't think of their names right now
but business podcasts and they do a lot
of thinking stuff and things like that
but that's really what I so no marriage
podcast so I guess so so what's your
example of marriage like are your
parents still together do you utilize
them as an example or like where do you
consume what it should look like oh
oh then there I have spiritual parents
as well who are like mentors mentees
they are a married couple as well I get
a lot of dating advice from them they're
heavily involved in the process just in
regards of like sometimes you get jaded
in that but I would say my parents um
are not together but my mom remarried
when I was seven so my stepdad has been
in my life since I was seven they have
been a good influence for me as well as
my aunt and uncle they've been married
um since I was in high school and he
plays they play a really big role in my
life so I have positive influences and
role models and I'm intentional when
dating you can't again always listen to
your friends and those type of things so
if you want to run to the people with
wisdom and experience and exposures and
just naturally how that has fallen is
that my parents I naturally order my
aunt who is my mom's sister she's a
little bit younger so she kind of gives
me the mid-age range and then my
spiritual parents while they are older
as well they're still kind of like
younger so I get wisdom from a plethora
of
um a range of age range right so they're
all bringing something different to the
table what's the last best meal that you
cooked oh I like this one um salmon and
asparagus soup that's a fave of mine
she's good what um so how did you cook
the salmon let's get in there a lot of
people are talking about they'd be
cooking this then the third how'd you
cook it let's talk about it come on
let's talk about it no people will
overcook their salmon so I always cook
my
you can make sure you can see you put it
in there you put the seasonings on there
you put it in there for about 15 minutes
so you pull it out then you got to get
the lemon juice can you put the lemon on
top of it cut up a couple of lemons put
it in there so that flavor can really
marinate put it back in the oven for
about five ten minutes look at it check
the temperature make sure it's pink a
little white but not you know to some
you want some moisture pull it on out
you put the asparagus in there they're
like five ten minutes done
it's a quick and easy meal as well but
it's one of my favorites it's so good
that's super dope what um what what is
your feeling about the word submission
listen I think it is
I I'm forcing
requires you to trust the person that
you're with so you have to choose who
you want to be submissive to right like
but I think it comes natural when you're
in a relationship where you trust the
person you want to be with them it's I'm
not going to question it like hey babe
can you go get me whatever like okay
cool I don't need to know why you need
me to go get something I don't need to
know whatever I know you got a plan
because I've been betting you and
trusting the process that you can lead
me where we're gonna get so it comes
naturally
I know it's a taboo wrote but it's super
terrible
I'm a Christian it's a part of what is
supposed to be the man is the lead right
like I'm really big into that and so but
I know as a woman we will fight that if
you're not with the person that you
trust then you're not in a safe
environment so the reality is our women
submissive all the time no and I
question who did you choose to be with
who did you choose to be with
accountability right that's the key word
all right so let me recap a couple of
things and by the way you can also ask
me questions as well oh I can't I didn't
know you know you
certain amount of time you're not you
know I have a couple questions a lot but
um
all right so
you cook
you seem to cook well
right you present yourself
as feminine
um you are an ambitious worker within
your career
right you've attained success being a
digital Nomad you can go wherever it is
that you want to go
you're 33 so I guess
bringing all of these to the table
generally is good things to have on a
resume why do you think that you're
still single at 33. that's a great
question because five years ago I wasn't
who I am today five years ago
we ain't never been a city girl yeah
foreign
dating relationships several years ago
and honestly I had some tough
conversations with people right I'm the
one who's open for feedback and one of
the greatest conversations but most
difficult conversations was this dude
told me I was contentious okay and from
that conversation it I really had to sit
with that and look back over my life and
I recognize that I wasn't just I was
contentious in my dating relationships
because I had been contentious I grew up
in a male environment right my mom
remarried I got two step brothers with
that I had already had a brother I grew
it was me and my mom in the household
and she worked a lot so it was a lot of
energy around me so that Babble that men
do with each other things like that I
was exposed to that I adopted that and I
became in that so while females were
supposed to be you know more quiet or
you know lend your opinion but do it in
a soft voice or things like that I was a
naturally conditioned to that even
though I'm naturally wired for it I
wasn't in environments that made a
conducive for that to be natural so I
had to take a pause out at like 28 29
which wasn't that long ago you know and
when you make intentional adjustments
you don't always see the fruit from that
immediately so I think I'm now just
really positioning myself to like I said
I'm ready now because I had to do some
work I wasn't I wasn't if you would have
seen me a few years without even like
yeah I see you got the job you got this
but it's something about you like she's
challenging she comes off you know a
little raw so um aggressive aggressive
even so you've been on a feminine
Journey absolutely for the last few very
intentional about it I got feedback from
male friends right I really put myself
to hear feedback and it wasn't nice
stuff my male friends would be like yeah
you're intimidating you're this you're
that and I was like no man wants to
settle with a woman who's that way so I
had to if I want to be married you got
to make the changes so I've been on a
journey to make those changes in the
last few years and I can say even for my
dating experiences it's been a game
changer if you were to get with me you'd
have the dead oil in your male friends
how was it that you feel about that
sacrifice do you think that men and
women can just can truly just be friends
outside of working
I do
things like that we're really brothers
and I think if you met them and you felt
that way then it's a done deal we've
already had these conversations because
men are more protective than females are
when they get married so all of my male
friends have already been conditioned
they already know when we were having
those similar conversations and I'm like
yo I'm about to make intentional changes
we looking for a husband that's what we
on that was a part of those
conversations so
I once again would want you to be open
to meeting them like hey meet them first
see the interactions they're married
they're this most of them live in my
hometown Chicago that I don't see often
years on at a time right and a lot of
them have our tour credit for the woman
that I've become and me recognizing me
so I think that's like a you know but if
ultimately right now I did it I don't
like it it's Gotta Go
I'm trying to be married they can't do
nothing for me they get they married
they got family they got kids
so my question for you
you ready
shoot okay you've been single for a real
real long time a real long time you
really think you ready and what
adjustments in your life would you have
to make to let somebody into your life
right now I'd have to make a lot of
adjustments I think a lot of um a lot of
adjustments from like a selfishness
perspective and I'm just saying that
from like a mature component of myself
is that you know when I wake up first of
all I'm an only child I was raised an
only child right like but it was a
single parent household it was just me
and my pops right so it's kind of
awesome
that's what it's usually yeah it is so
that's a different Dynamic okay it was
just me and my pop shout out to my pops
but um it was just me and him and um you
know within that
um and understanding kind of the things
that I had to do in order to build the
business that I have right now it's like
it's completely focused on myself within
my purpose and within the things my
business perspective did the lighting
just change what's up we got the Red
Light Special I did get it here
oh we got one minute left
oh come into it and I know you're gonna
miss me
look at the
oh Lord we doing a deep in introspect
where the camera at hold on
okay okay nice if they were maybe two
centimeters longer I you'd have to you'd
have to go you have to I gotta type I
gotta you know this is the longest
though yeah yeah
let me try to keep it classy neutral
colors excuse me so so if I asked you
about
um the removal of your male friends when
you was 27 you would have told me to go
f myself
so let me ask you what what what about
like the way that you were raised do you
think that you you know that you would
that you form that degree of
contentiousness or aggressiveness when
it comes to
this is great thank you for your time
over here
guys as I'm Gonna Keep a funky with you
when I hear the resume and then I see
the age I begin to think conditional
femininity that's why I asked her
specific to what's the content that she
consumed because I wanted to try to
understand how far along her femininity
Journey has she gone on right because we
talk about this on the channel is you
know is she learning different things
within the game on how to act but it's
not actually a component
of her character it's very important to
understand so but all in all I thought
that she was a sweetheart I didn't see a
majority of red flags that I normally
see in dating situations so we'll see so
you don't care about marriage I
don't know
I got the shot
[Music]
thank you